وجه الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
انتقادات من الجمهوريين بعد سلسله من
الخسائر في الانتخابات النصفيه طالت
المرشحين الذين اختارهم هذا الامر قد يضعف
موقف ترامب الى حد ما وسط توقعات باعلانه
عن الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
ومع العدد الهائل من الفرص الجمهوريه
الضائعه كان الاندفاع لالقاء اللون على
نيه على ترامب فوريا بقدر ما كان مفاجئا
وفقا لتقرير نشرته صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الامريكيه عدد كبير من الجمهوريين انتقدوا
ترامب على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ووسائل
الاعلام مشيرين الى انه مسؤول الى حد كبير
عن النتائج المخيبه للامال للانتخابات
النصفيه حيث تمت هزيمه عدد من المرشحين
الذين كان قد ايدهم في سباقات التنافسيه
بما في ذلك المرشحون لمنصب الحاكم ومقعد
مجلس الشيوخ في ولايه سلفانيا والمرشحون
منصب الحاكم في ولايات ميشيغنوان نيويورك
[موسيقى]